Okay, so let's talk a little bit more about
why we would use MongoDB. One of the most important
reasons to use MongoDB is because it has a flexible
schema. This enables us to more easily handle data in
flat formats, such as CSV, and also hierarchical data, where
individual fields Are composed of multiple elements. MongoDB is also
oriented toward programmers. One way we see this is that
the type of JSON documents stored in MongoDB map directly
onto familiar data types found in most popular
programming languages. Such as the examples we saw; php
arrays, Python dictionaries, etcetera. Another place we see this
is in the MongoDB Client Libraries, or drivers as
we call them. MongoDB supports drivers for most popular
programming languages. These drivers handle the job of translating
the data to and from native data types within
the particular language as needed by the application, and
also support a number of other features That make
it easy to develop applications using MongoDB. Another feature
that makes MongoDB great for data scientists is your
ability to deploy MongoDB in a variety of ways.
So for example in just a couple of minutes
you can download install and run MongoDB on your
laptop and quickly begin developing an application on your
laptop. Or you can deploy MongoDB on multiple servers.
With several demons running to support a big data application. And,
of course, there are lots of options in between these two.
MongoDB is designed for big data. It's highly scalable horizontally, on
commodity hardware, and includes native support for Map Reduce. And it
includes the aggregation framework. That
enables efficient analytics applications. Okay so
enough chatter about MongoDB, let's dive in and actually start using it.